bonjour nicolas mirkovic merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france
crise escalade de tension en tout cas
entre le kosovo et la serbie à quoi ça
tient expliquez-nous à l'origine de
cette escalade et et verrons ça peut
dégénérer
depuis une semaine les albanais du
kosovo dont qui ont organisé une
administration qui n'est pas reconnu par
belgrade et qui n'est pas reconnu par
une majorité d'habitants de la planète
ont décidé de manière unilatérale de ne
plus reconnaître les plaques
d'immatriculation des véhicules servent
donc il ya à peu près un peu moins de
cent cinquante mille serbes qui habite
au kosovo métochie aujourd'hui ils vont
régulièrement entre ce qu'on appelle la
serbie centrale qui est juste au nord du
kosovo et le kosovo est depuis lundi
dernier les autorités l'administration
kosovare ne reconnaît pas ces véhicules
est dit qu ils ces véhicules doivent
avoir une plaque au moins temporaire que
se voir ce que ces serbes refusent ces
serbes on s'estime vivant en serbie est
en serbe est donc sacrée cette crise
parce que l'administration albanaise a
envoyé ses forces spéciales et que du
coup bas en représailles les serbes ont
organisé des grèves ont bloqué les
routes et donc du coup la tension ne
cesse de monter c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui un belgrade déploie ses
troupes parce qu'il y à une crainte
d'une expulsion des serbes du nord du
kosovo et que cet état de non
reconnaissance des plaques ne serait
qu'une première étape a dans une radio
une volonté de vouloir chasser les
serbes définitivement du kosovo alors
les états unis dans ce contexte l europe
ont appelé au dialogue le premier
ministre kosovar lui a accusé la serbie
de chercher à provoquer un sérieux
conflit international est ce que c'est
un scénario possible
tout est arrivé dans les balkans tout
peut arriver conseils concernant ce
sujet très épineux du kosovo ce qui est
certain c'est que c'est clairement
l'administration albanaise qui est à
l'origine de cette tension puisque c'est
elle qui tout d'un coup a décidé de ne
plus reconnaître les plaques
d'immatriculation le cern donc du coup
elle doit assumer cette responsabilité
en plus elle a envoyé ses forces
spéciales de la situation est très
tendue ce n'est pas juste une décision
administrative ya des forces spéciales
des hommes en armes cagoulés qui sont en
train d'inspecter que les voitures il ya
des des malveillances qui sont kisumu d
candide et des agressions une tension
vis-à-vis de ces serbes qui est discute
qui refuse de prendre ces nouvelles
plaques oui ça peut dégénérer ça peut
dégénérer malheureusement on voit que
malgré la présence de l'otan malgré de
nombreux émissaires envoyés par
bruxelles pour essayer de régler le
problème du kosovo depuis ces vingt
dernières années on voit la situation
n'est toujours pas réglée cette crise
n'est qu'une nouvelle crise dans une
série de crise que vit le kosovo depuis
cessé ces dernières décennies et on voit
très bien l'incapacité de bruxelles et
de washington de pacifier et de régler
définitivement la situation pour que
tous les peuples qu'il soit albanaise ou
serbe puissent vivre en paix dans la
région
bref vous le disiez l'otan qui est qui
et sur place que peuvent-ils faire
concrètement on sait que le président
serbe s'est entretenu avec jens
stoltenberg le secrétaire général de
l'otan
c'est évidemment très très très
difficile on voit difficilement comment
est ce que le président serre pourrait
engager henin et l'offensive militaire
parce qu'en effet il ya le temps qui est
présent au kosovo le kosovo ne fait pas
partie de l'otan mais on sait que c'est
une création américaine c'est un
protectorat américain avec des hommes de
sécurité de de l'otan sur place pour
autant les serres ne sont pas seuls ils
ont le soutien de la russie
l'ambassadeur de russie en serbie a
était avec stefanovich hier voir la
frontière à l'est les troupes serbes on
sait que la chine était également un
très très grand un très grand défenseur
de la position de la serbie au sein du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu donc du
coup la serbie n'est pas seul je pense
que le belgrade deux clament montrer ses
muscles elle dit à la communauté
internationale que cette situation doit
changer immédiatement de revenir à la
normale et je note que charles michel le
président du conseil européen lui même
hier a demandé à ce que les albanais on
retire leurs forces spéciales du nord du
kosovo où vit une majorité de serbes je
pense que ce que veut belgrade s'est
montrée à la communauté internationale
et notamment aux partenaires occidentaux
de l'ouest que là elle ne rigole pas et
que là vraiment cette situation doit
s'inverser très rapidement on peut donc
imaginer un nouveau point de crispation
entre les etats-unis et la russie
aujourd'hui
fait tout à fait puisque du coup lors
landat aussi rappelle non seulement la
position de belgrade mais c'est
important de rappeler que la russie
soutient la position de l'onu que le
kosovo aujourd'hui sur la résolution 240
cas de l'onu fait partie de la serbie et
ça a été un point d'achoppement depuis
ces vingt dernières années c'est un
point d'achoppement majeur qui est un
point d'achoppement sur la souveraineté
des états et sur le respect du droit
international
les etats-unis ont créé le kosovo mais
ils sont désintéresse maintenant ils
sont des intérêts ce qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de mener toutes
leurs guerres à l'étranger tous leurs
protecteurs on l'a vu avec l'afghanistan
certains spécialistes demandent si le
kosovo ne sera pas le prochain
afghanistan abandonnés par les
américains les américains n'arrivent pas
à régler la situation ils ont dit qu'il
le règle leur est bruxelles regarde ne
fait rien comme d'habitude ça peut
escalader et ce sera un point de tension
entre deux frissons entre eux entre
moscou et les washington et moscou
rappellera à washington qu aux yeux du
droit international le kosovo et de la
métochie faut capter de la serbie merci
beaucoup nicolas mirkovic une avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france